running into an X can be awkward but not
when you're Kim Kardashian and Pete
Davidson you just gotta roll with it the
two were snapped chatting it up at the
Met Gala earlier this week and now a
source tells E.T there are zero hard
feelings between them in fact everything
was totally fine so that's really
meaningful to me so what did the X's
talk about according to our source Pete
was a gentleman and complimented Kim's
look and style which she appreciated
thank you of course last year things
looked a little different because Kim
and Pete attended the Met Gala together
foreign
like so cute
yeah he's just super genuine but the two
called it quits in August after nine
months of dating and now Pete is dating
his bubkist co-star Chase sui wonders
but when it comes to Kim and Pete's
history
ET Source says they respect each other
he knows Kim was looking to have fun
when they dated and he was totally fine
with it he also enjoyed their time
together babe do you want to shower with
me really quick
what just happened the two started
dating after Kim hosted Saturday Night
Live in 2021 months after filing for
divorce from Kanye West Are You Gonna
Kiss Me Or Not I sure am Jasmine
E.T Source says it was great for Kim to
date someone like Pete after her
relationship with the rapper saying it
was exactly what she needed at the time
I love that he's kind and really really
thoughtful he's the most thoughtful
person and I love the chemistry that Kim
and him have together it's really sweet
I thought you said the chemistry I was
like okay chemistry chemistry as for
Pete our source says he thinks Kim is a
great person but their relationship was
a little too much for him with all the
press and Kanye drama
and speaking of Kanye he's moved on with
architectural designer Bianca sensori
ET sour says Kim doesn't know Bianca
well but as long as she's a good person
and her ex is happy then Kim's happy
that would be my goal that would be the
ultimate dream but what about Kim
finding love again well we hear she's
being laid back about dating is in no
rush to meet someone and is comfortable
being single Kim's just living her best
life and isn't taking herself too
seriously I don't know what's going to
top that she
who right now and everyone around her
loves it
[Music]
thank you